el canal de suez sigue bloqueado con ese
buque portacontenedores el ever given
que lleva desde el martes varado cruzado
en esa vía marítima tan importante las
labores para intentar desbloquear lo han
sido fallidas hasta el momento más de 8
remolcadores lo han estado intentando y
hoy ha llegado a egipto desde alemania
un equipo de expertos para intentar
ayudar a los egipcios a lograr que se
mueva ese enorme barco que tiene
dimensiones de rascacielos tiene más de
400 metros de largo y más de 55 casi 60
de ancho el tamaño del empire state y
además el peso es otro de los grandes
problemas para mover lo más de 224 mil
toneladas se cree que se podría aligerar
un poco la carga removiendo parte de
esos contenedores pero eso podría tardar
días o incluso semanas algo en lo que no
quiere pensar ninguno de los expertos
que están trabajando en el desbloqueo
por supuesto el gobierno egipcio porque
eso supondría el retraso en el comercio
internacional por esta vía tan
importante pasa al menos
el 12% del comercio mundial y entre
ellos también el 7% del crudo
algo que provocó inmediato miedo en los
mercados y también el aumento del barril
de brent en un 3% en los próximos días
se espera que los egipcios consigan
llevar a cabo esas tareas y moverlo pero
ese peso esas grandes dimensiones y
sobre todo la mala climatología que
todavía continúa estos días y que fue la
principal causa por la que quedó varado
todavía continúan